hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the feed hs olympiad here we have a
very nice game between wesley so
representing united states and yamakura
sindarov representing uzbekistan this is
board three and the game is just uh well
it's a joy to watch you guys will enjoy
it and the round four is basically the
start of the big clashes here on the
board one for example fabiano caruana is
facing the world the rapid champ
champion notre because
and um well every board is really
action-packed uh
not gonna spoil too much but we are
going to discuss a little bit uh what
happens on the other boards after we
check out the game so let's dive
straight into it wesley has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 uh c for g6 and here wesley
lounges forward with h4 and this is
already extremely exciting uh as this is
only the seventh most popular now moving
this position uh standard moves are some
like knight c3 knight f3 g3 and
some other moves but h3
it's not incredibly rare but uh like i
said seventh most popular we have c5 now
striking in the center uh going after
that d4 pawn d5 and now b5 basically
playing the uh benko gambit uh with
white having this weird h4 on the uh on
the on the board but um uh like i said i
i i it's uh not nothing new it has been
played before by some incredibly strong
players so c characters on b5 and now a6
much like you would in a
standard bangko gambit and here pawn to
e3 uh there is a game between uh wesley
and topalov and anish giri where b
captures on a6 was played the game ended
in a draw but it is considered stronger
to play e3 so e3 here and now we have a
characters on b5 again there is a very
well-known game where bishop the g7 was
played it was played in a game between
alexander grishok and maxime vashila
grav mvl won this game very nicely but
here eight characters on b5 ended now
bishop captures um on b5 grabbing that
pawn back with queen to a5 check
attacking the bishop knight to c3 and
now uh there is a game where knight the
e4 was played but here we have bishop to
a6 by cinderella and it is now as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game so let's see how wesley deals with
this uh awkward position already and
move six but uh of all the players in
the world this is something that wesley
so uh does not mind at all as you guys
know he is the world fisher random
champion and the crazier the position it
is the more it will favor him so it is
very
very
uh brave of of young cinder of here
playing like this against wesley uh but
okay bishop captures on a6 we have queen
captures and then now knight g to e2 of
course you have to block this diagonal
if you are the castle so bishop to g7
and the bald player's castle and here
wesley's saying okay i'm up a pawn you
have some compensation that is uh
well it's very similar to what you would
have in in a bangko gambit you have the
beautiful bishop here
uh sorry the beautiful bishop here you
you have the rook on the a file you
probably the other one is coming to the
b file maybe something with knight a6
knight to c7 uh the standard ideas so
here we have a4 by wesley
uh preparing that outpost for the knight
on b5 and queen to c4 now now before the
queen is locked out of the game with
knight to b5 but also this comes with
tempo as the h4 pawn is hanging so
wesley defends it pawn to g3 and now how
do you continue this with black well
what we've discussed is the
probably the best thing to do just some
like d6 knight a6 knight to c7 the other
rook to b8 and you have all of this
pressure for the price of one pawn it's
definitely not bad however uh here um
cinderella plays e6 and he gives wesley
an opportunity to play a move that uh
directly takes a advantage of this um
well uh
e6 move so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this move
that
wesley may or may not have played while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of positional play and of the for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course pawn to b3 and now
of course that you see it you
immediately believe it uh this
is a very very strong as it comes with
an attack on the queen so basically what
um cinder did when he played e6 is he
opened up this diagonal and wesley now
wants to put his bishop on a three and
he does so with tempo of course as now
uh the queen needs to react to this move
so here we have queen to g4
uh and now comes bishop to a3 and how
are you how are you playing this it's a
very very clumsy position to have for
black because if this
if this pawn falls then you no longer
have the standard uh
uh position where you know you have
compensation you you you have to fight
against the past a and b pawn if the c
pawn falls so here at knight to a6 of
course we're defending the pawn and not
rook to c1 putting more pressure on the
c pawn and of course getting the rook
away from that a1 square and here we
have e captures on d5
rook if the c8 or something like e5
might be a little bit better but still
it's very very hard to make a move here
for black so here he captures and e5 was
played and now wesley just brings the
another attacker into the game knight to
f4
goes after the d5 pawn and also offers a
queen trade so here uh we have rook f
the b8 uh the rook definitely belongs
here and now knight to b5 now you can
trade queens and you don't have to worry
about losing the b3 pawn queen captures
on d1 uh we have rook capture on d1 and
now pawn to d6 even defending the c5
pawn which seems like uh is something
that the wesley should not have allowed
but wesley says nope uh this completely
winning for me and black is basically
without a move here so bishop back to b2
now getting ready to eliminate the
knight uh it seems odd giving up your
dark square bishop for a knight here but
it it will simply remove the defender
here of the d5 pawn and then
well
wait and see so here rook to b7 and now
just the bishop characters on f6 bishop
characters and knight captures on the e5
now threatening the bishop bishop back
to g7 and now rook to d3 we have rook a
to b8 but now just pawn to g4 wesley not
even
uh looking at this uh d6 pawn for the
moment he will first prepare everything
and then uh will he go after the spawn
uh you don't want to give black anything
in return and it's uh well
just impossible to to get the rooks into
the game you can't bring the knight into
the game with wesley controlling the c7
square like this so
everything is on a light square the dark
square bishop is pretty useless here so
wesley plays g4 he might play g5 uh
constraint uh the the movements uh
around the black king even further we
have c for now uh giving up uh uh a
point uh to get this knight to the c5
square and then maybe win the b3 pawn
but it is uh not going to help him all
that much rook captures on c4 knights to
c5 attacking the rook rook to d1 knight
captures on b3 so you do win this spawn
but now finally knight captures on d6
and uh it doesn't matter what you play
europe is attacked rook to a7 was played
here wesley played knight to c8 and he
was in this position unmoved 28 yes
you've heard that correctly and move 28
that yabukir sindarov resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the rook is attacked there's uh no
good square for the rook and well the e
seven square is under wasteless control
so knight a7 check is coming on the next
move then rook the d80 check is coming
there is no stopping this for example if
you go here knight check if you go here
this is checkmate if you go to h8 then
we deliver another check you have to
give up the bishop and now it would be a
king hunt for example rock the g8
checking f6 g5 check e6 now rook d8 with
the threat of rook to e4 checkmate so
there's no
it would be pointless to even try to
defend this so after knight to c8 uh
java cricindaro resigned and a beautiful
victory for wesley so not just for
himself but also for team united states
as this um definitely means a lot
winning this quickly against uh
such such a young team and now the other
players will have to push very very hard
to fight back and it seems that they are
doing uh quite a good job it seems that
on on board four uh shankland is lost
and fabi uh also seems to be a
bit in trouble uh on board one uh i left
the position i started recording when it
was still move 45 he had to make one
more move to reach time control and it
was uh there was only one move that fabi
can make otherwise he's just dead lost
so you know we'll see if he did it uh
you know if that's the next video i'm
making then chances are he missed the
idea there but we'll see how it goes uh
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh like i said very brave
going for something like this against
wesley so but wesley is a world fisher
random champion and uh
even magnus
[Music]
you know uh has incredible difficulty
playing uh weird positions against
wesley so this was a fine attempt uh but
wesley just shows why he is absolutely
world class
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank david kimura and
michaela kalista harper isla uh esmond
alden and jacob tobias for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on one
of suggestions and uh finishing uh well
continuing the uh
uh games of the of the chess olympiad uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day